Good morning Hank.
It's Tuesday.
So, you recently made a video outside, and
I was like, "We have outside in Indiana."
So, yeah, here I am.
One of my favorite words in English is "mortification".
It's also one of my least favorite things
to experience, and last week, I was well and
truly mortified when I used the word "hectacre",
like, 135 times in my video about agriculture
in Ethiopia.
I said "hectacre", like, one who takes hec
when in fact, I meant hectare, meaning one
hundred ares, with are being a unit of measure
that means one hundred square meters.
Now, admittedly, units measuring land area:
not among my fields of expertise, but still,
I was trying to share with people what I'd
learned about how to make more food available
to hungry people, but obviously, I knew absolutely
nothing because hectacre!
Hank, I've only experienced real mortification
a couple times in my adult life, like my first
book signing after Looking for Alaska was
published was only attended by two people.
Now, that was obviously concerning, but it
wasn't really mortifying until I was halfway
through my reading, and I read a sentence
from the book that went, "The only thing worse
than having a party that no one attends is
having a party attended by two vastly, deeply
uninteresting people," thereby managing to
insult the only two people nice enough to
come to my signing.
Then, a few years later, I was giving a talk
to several hundred high school students, none
of whom had any idea who I was, and I talked
for forty-five minutes.
Everyone was laughing a lot.
They seemed to be having a great time, and
then, finally, I was like, "Are there any
questions?"
at which point several dozen people raised
their hands, which is very unusual, and I
was like, "Yeah, yes, do you have a question?"
and they were like, "Yeah, Mr. Green, are
you aware that your fly is open?"
Now, Hank, to be clear, it wasn't that my
zipper was down.
My fly was open.
Like, you could see my underwear.
And then, I was like, "No, I wasn't aware
that my fly was down."
I turned around, I zipped up my fly, I turned
back around, and I was like, "Are there any
other questions?"
Silence.
Wait, have I told that story in a Vlogbrothers
video before?
Now, I feel a little bit of mortification
creeping in again.
Blergh.
I don't even know what's been in my own videos.
But anyway, back to hectacre.
So, Sarah was trying to comfort me and she
was like, "You know, nerdfighters don't care
that much about this stuff.
They're so forgiving and nice.
It'll be fine," and she was also like, "Now,
no offense, but it's not like that many people
outside of Nerdfighteria are going to see
your video because, you know, it's about agricultural
yields in the developing world.
It's not- it's not going to catch fire on
Tumblr," and then, of course, within a day,
Bill Gates, the head of The World Food Program,
and the foreign minister of Ethiopia had all
seen the video.
Now, they were all very nice about it, but
you know that secretly, they were like, "Hectacre?"
So, it's one thing to look like a grapefruit
in front of Nerdfighteria, Hank; they've come
to expect it, but Bill Gates?
Mortifying.
Now, when mortification is something that
you're doing entirely to yourself, as it was
in this instance, there can be something useful
about it maybe, like I want to seem like the
kind of person who knows a lot about agriculture
or the kind of person who can get through
a two-person book signing without alienating
the audience, and mortification can be your
ideas about yourself being challenged by the
reality of yourself, and that's not such a
bad thing, but when other people try to mortify
you, when they say cruel things about you
to make you feel embarrassed of yourself or
when they read your diary or share pictures
that you wish to remain private, that's very
different.
I don't think anything is gained there, and
a lot is lost.
Hank, I don't think any of us can navigate
the world always having to be our public selves
even when in private because I think we'd
go mad.
Now, God knows I'll never say "hectacre" in
a Vlogbrothers video again, but if I can't
say it at home, I'm seriously kind of doomed
because then I'd lose touch with my real and
actual self, which, for all of us, is necessarily
different from the selves we project in public.
We all act differently in private than we
do in school or at our jobs or on Tumblr.
Now, Hank, I can't speak for everyone, but
I for one wouldn't want to have to be on Tumblr
all the time.
Well- no, no, no, because my kids don't have
Tumblrs.
Yet.
Anyway, Hank, if you've learned one thing
from being my brother, I hope it is this:
hectare!
Rhymes with nectar almost.
Rhymes with lecture.
Not really.
Those, by the way, are called slant rhymes,
he said confidently, feeling a whisper of
doubt.
I'll see you on Friday.